everybody has it as a kit once you start
getting schooled you get indoctrinated
to believe what success is supposed to
look like which is being disciplined
being responsible achieving things
getting married having a good job and
then that becomes the primary focus and
then the voice of curiosity or the still
Small Voice gets filed away in the
extracurricular activity folder
coexisting with that voice you have the
voices of your teachers your parents
social conditioning culture the news
right but the only thing that determines
how loud a specific voice is which one
you follow the most whichever one you
should eat the most that's the one
that's gonna be the loudest